well it's funny brother just to jump in
to get valued everybody that's why I'm
so passionate about the marketing stuff
nothing comes less than me than the
process I've gone through in the last
eight years to get into better physical
health my brain goes to if I figured
this out starting at 38 after doing
nothing I had 0.0 muscle in my body at
38 and only consumed soda and sugar
until my face fell off for me to be able
to win that game makes me feel that
anybody here who's like I don't like
technology I don't like this is capable
of winning this if they want why did I
do it because I'd like to live longer
why am I asking you to do this because
you'd like your business to be better